just come over to sing the theme song ET
first met Tom Hanks in 1982 on the set
of his show bosom buddies I've been told
by people in real life that
hey you're a wimp on TV you look huge 37
years later he's being honored with the
Cecil B deMille Award at the 77th annual
Golden Globe Awards hey it's a nice day
that's a good day now he T is looking
back at the life and career of one of
Hollywood's most beloved stars I've
known I've been a funny guy for a long
time Tom put his comedic skills to work
in the 1988 like big I just pretended to
be 12 years old which is kind of what
you do when you're an actor anyway the
role landed him his first Oscar nom
there is just some sort of intrinsic
truth to every script that it comes in
that you either react to and relate to
or you don't I thought was just very
true I thought it was very touching I
thought it was very at the same time
uplifting that it is heartbreaking you
have to have this element of truth
that's going to touch us as human beings
and they did Tom went from big to the
big leagues he was on the set of Tom's
1992 movie a league of their own crying
in baseball what was it like doing a
movie surrounded by women like that it
was paradise on earth absolute paradise
the flick was a smash at the box office
grossing over 132 million dollars
worldwide
one year later Tom teamed up with meg
Ryan in Sleepless in Seattle bringing us
rom-com gold this script was such a
cohesive whole movie
I knew exactly what the guy was going
through when I read it I was compelled
by what this character was going through
he also got a little screen time with
his wife Rita Wilson oh you're kidding
that's so sweet oh it was really fun it
was really fun at home we save on gas
one year later Tom brought home his
first Oscar win for his performance in
Philadelphia I have a case if you don't
want it for personal reasons
thank you that's correct I don't
well thank you for your time the great
honor is to be nominated I think that
the first time it happens you're in a
world and you can't believe it because
it's just too exciting the second time
it happens it's a different kind of
excitement because I really never
thought that it would happen again that
it that it that it has means that I get
to go to my grave there's a two-time
Academy Award nominee that's a very
special thing he went back-to-back
winning Best Actor in a leading role
again in 1995 came out okay maybe I'm
nuts this time for his role as Forrest
Gump my mom always said life was like a
box of chocolates you never know what
you're going to get that same year Tom
brought woody to life in Disney's Toy
Story
[Music]
no woody is so volatile he yells a lot
so that you know my vocal cords would be
in shreds after a while my diaphragm
would be stretched out of me okay go
home hard I feel I said John you know I
mean movies where I'd carried guys
through the jungle you know for weeks at
a time and I've never been as tired as I
am right now
I'm exhausted he landed another Oscar
nom in 1999 for his role in Saving
Private Ryan you feel like you've won
the lottery somehow and you feel like
wait a minute
first of all I get to make the movie
first of all they pay me to make the
movie then I get to make a movie the guy
likes but then I get to make a movie
that turns out as good as this one has
and again in 2001 for castaway I'm the
luckiest man in the world I can't
believe that I've received the nods that
the times I have and would do it again I
would I'd be thunderstruck tom has also
won seven Emmys and four Golden Globes
this year he's nominated for his
portrayal as mr. Rogers in a beautiful
day in the neighborhood please won't you
be my neighbor
I think mr. Fred Rogers is the first
person I played that is not undergoing
the great crisis of their of their
business or their lines mr. Rogers
doesn't want anything except for people
maybe to understand themselves in the
world a little bit better
[Music]